a new app allows people to put their
faces into movies and TV shows by
uploading a single photo but there could
be a potential cost to a users privacy
one user posted this video on Twitter
saying he was able to become Leonardo
DiCaprio in under 8 seconds by using the
Chinese app sow the app is currently
only available in China but it raises
new concerns that fake videos are
becoming too realistic and your face
could be used for anything CBS News
contributor and wired editor-in-chief
Nick Thompson is here to help us
understand what is known as deep fake
technology you were here you were real
this is not a simulation what are the
concerns it seems like a lot of fun it
is a lot of fun and that's why it's
become so popular so quickly the
concerns are that people can take your
image and you whatever they want with it
in China in particular where your image
is used for financial transactions
having somebody create realistic
simulations of your face is scary
there's other apps that can do this what
makes this one different well makes this
one different is that it's really good
and it came up with a very clever idea
of creating a bunch of set movie scenes
or TV scenes and allowing you to put
your face into those scenes it was a
brilliant idea for an app so I can be
Jennifer Lopez and hustler you should do
it I don't know
so my feeling about this is that there
are real privacy concerns right and the
Terms of Service initially when the app
launched we're quite bad and they said
we can do whatever we want with your
face for as long as we want it we can
even give it to the government for
whatever purpose they might have so
that's concerning however for a public
figure or for someone who shares their
face all over the place as all four of
us do yeah I don't see why it's
particularly bad if you're a dissident
if you're an undercover operative if
you're concerned about Chinese state
surveillance don't use this app I mean I
think a lot of people in China are
certainly a lot of people in Hong Kong I
mean absolutely raises bigger questions
about 2020 right so Adam Schiff a
Democratic congressman said that there
are nightmarish scenarios tied to this
technology into 2020 we used to be able
to believe what you see with your eyes
or hear with your ears but now you can't
anymore
right absolutely so in 2020 it is highly
likely that someone will make
kind of a very realistic fake video one
of the candidates saying something that
they didn't say or doing something they
didn't do that's concerning
but candidates also have cameras with
them all the time it's relatively easy
to disprove what I worry about the most
is bullying and kids created videos of
classmates there's a lot of bad stuff
that you can do with this technology to
really hurt people's feelings that may
be worse than what's gonna happen in
politics how's the company reacted to
the criticism they said whoa sorry about
that
I mean the app launched it shot up to
the top of the charts backlash was
immediate and they said okay we're
changing our privacy policies we're
changing our Terms we'll delete your
information if you delete the app we're
sorry but they got sort of suspended by
WeChat they've had a lot of problems
because of the privacy backlash which is
interesting because in America we
sometimes think the people in China
don't care about privacy yeah clearly
they do this works both directions right
if somebody could create a fake video of
a political candidate or a genuine video
of a political candidate doing something
that is politically relevant that Kanaka
didn't say I don't think it's me you
know that's not me in blackface or
that's not me singing that particular
song or making those particular comments
absolutely so we're gonna need real
verification technology which
fortunately some people are working on
good to hear all right thank you very
much